of course i'm not going to fight 10
girls i'm not hitting one girl damn sure
not 10.
hey guys you're great you're just
there's there's so few people here
that we can hear everything you're
saying
yeah there's nothing to feel bad about
do you want to sit closer would you like
to sit against the ball
uh okay i truly you could get the [ __ ]
out i really don't care
i really don't care y'all can get the
[ __ ] out all right
[Applause]
oh my god it was my girl facetiming me
hey baby
10 black girls almost beat the [ __ ] out
of me on stage this is
crazy they were [ __ ] four feet from
me this whole shitty ass audience didn't
do nothing
they just sat there and watched it
happen they were like i ain't the one
and i was like [ __ ]
i'm realizing that now
can you believe this [ __ ] i can't
believe it i'm telling you i almost got
killed on stage they're legit still
waiting upstairs
every once in a while i look up like oh
[ __ ] they're still up there
and you're asking about the [ __ ]
apple tv password are you crazy right
now
you know how much i love this girl this
is break up with a bull offense
if i love her any less i'd be like i
told you almost got killed
and you're talking about [ __ ]
ted lasso right now are you crazy
i was scared for my life
she just said bye can you at least
acknowledge that i almost got killed boo
women
yes i'm sorry
she loves me i know she loves me she
also doesn't mind if i die clearly
all you have to say what's your
follow-up i'll watch on the other tv
i can you [ __ ] believe
what's up guys thanks for watching the
video if you're a fan just hit subscribe
stop hating what are you waiting for
that way you'll get updated whenever i
put up new videos and we got a lot
coming after warranty